Ce que je trouve fou avec pi c'est qu'on le
trouve vraiment partout. Déjà, en géométrie
bien sûr
parce que pi est, comme vous le savez très
bien, défini comme le ratio de la circonférence
du cercle par son diamètre. Et ce qui est
déjà fou c'est que c'est vrai pour tous
les cercles, même
si vous prenez un cercle qui fait le tour
de l'univers tout entier, prenez sa circonférence
et divisez le par son diamètre : vous obtenez
pi. Autre chose d'incroyable, prenez un bout
de ficelle et faites le tour de la terre,
devinez combien il faut rajouter à ce bout
de ficelle pour que lorsqu'on étend de la
ficelle, on obtient maintenant une ficelle
qui soit partout un mètre au dessus du niveau
du sol : il faut rajouter 2 fois pi mètres.
Mais si pi est si fou, c'est qu'il apparait
bien ailleurs qu'en géométrie. Par exemple,
l'une des formules des plus folles qui existent
est une formule due a un certain Madhavar,
un Indien du 14e siècle qui dit que pi est
exactement égal à 4 - 4/3 + 4/5 - 4/7 +…
,etc.
Il est ou le cercle la? Et en fait quand on
joue avec des nombres infinis, de nombres
assez simples comme ça, on obtient rapidement
des trucs incroyables. Le maitre en la matière
est un certain Leonhar Euler, qui a prouvé
entre autre que la somme des
inverses des carrés 1 + 1/4 +1/9 + 1/16 +
,etc. jusqu'à l'infini est égale exactement
à pi carré sur 6. Pourquoi pi carré sur
6?
Euler a surtout prouvé une formule incroyable
qui relie pi à des nombres incroyables des
mathématiques : la fameuse formule e i pi
+ 1 égal a zéro. Donc pi apparait beaucoup
dans ces sommes infinies et en analyse en
général. Mais pi apparait aussi de façon
surprenante en arithmétique. Prenez deux
nombres au hasard et regardez leur facteur
premier : la probabilité qu'il n'y ait aucun
facteur commun est 6/picarré. Et pi apparait
aussi en probabilité : prenez une ardoise
et tracez des
trais horizontaux séparés de deux fois la
longueur d'une aiguille, jetez plein d'aiguilles
sur cette feuille. Alors la probabilité qu'une
aiguille intersecte une ligne va être égale
à 1/pi.
Enfin pi apparait aussi en musique, de façon
un petit peu cachée cette fois. La découverte
fondamentale de l'histoire de la musique
est qu'on pouvait résumer la musique
en les fréquences qui sont jouées, c'est
pour ça que les partitions montrent les fréquences
qui sont jouées plutôt que le signal sonore,
qui est en fait une perturbation de l'air.
Pas de l'air, Euler mais de l'air !
Bref il y a une connexion intime et extrêmement
importante entre
le signal et les variation de la pression
qu'il joue et les fréquences qui lui permettent
de jouer les partitions de la musique. Le
lien entre les deux
est ce qu'on appelle
la transformée de Fourier et quand on transfère
l'un en l'autre puis
l'autre en l'un, de plein
de façons assez
mystiques, apparait ce fameux nombre pi. Et
donc ce qui est donc vraiment incroyable avec
pi c'est qu'il a été inventé pour de la
géométrie, mais il apparait également en
analyse, en arithmétique,
en probabilité et même en musique ou plutôt
en théorie de Fourier.
mais ce n'est pas le plus fou avec pi,
croyez moi. En tout cas ce qui est pour moi
le plus fou avec pi,
ce n'est pas tant ce que l'on sait de lui
mais plutôt ce que l'on se sait
pas de lui. Et pendant longtemps on n'a pas
su grand chose de lui, pi vraiment est insaisissable.
En Grèce antique, la légende des mathématiques
était un certain Pythagore, et je parle bien
de légende parce que son existence n'est
pas avérée.
Pythagore avait trouvé l'harmonie de la musique
a travers des
ratios de nombres entier et du coup il pensait
que tout était fait de ratio d'entiers. En
tout cas tout ce qui était joli. Ce qui l'aura
conduit selon la légende
à noyer l'un de ses disciples pour avoir
osé révéler au monde
entier
que racine carrée de 2
n'est pas un ratio.
Et d'ailleurs pi non plus n'est pas un ratio,
pi n'est pas
rationnel :
pi est irrationnel, sans doute un petit peu
comme ces politiciens de l'Indiana qui à
la fin du 19e siècle n'arrivant pas a
capturer pi,
ont choisi
d'imposer par la loi
une valeur à pi. Par la loi ils ont voté
que pi est égal à 3,2.
Pendant ce temps, les mathématiciens eux
cherchaient a capturer pi avec
leurs outils préférés c'est à dire les
équations. Mais pi ne peut pas être capturé
avec des équations non plus
car pi n'est pas algébrique.
pi est transcendental !
Tout ça est ce que l'on sait de pi aujourd'hui.
Mais le plus fou avec pi,
c'est plutôt ce qu'on ne sait
pas de lui aujourd'hui.
On ne sait même pas si pi est un nombre
normal. Comment ça normal, pi est déjà
transcendantal ? Comment
peut-il être normal? En fait la plupart des
nombres normaux sont transcendantaux
et vice versa c'est un petit peu bizarre.
Et du coup c'est quoi un nombre normal?
Un nombre est normal si ses décimales ont
l'air assez aléatoires.
Oui je sais que cela n'a pas l'air très mathématique
mais il y a une façon
de le formaliser. En tout cas, ce qui est
fou si un nombre est
normal
ou bien juste il est
un nombre univers
c'est que si vous prenez n'importe quel
nombre,
vous le retrouverez dans les décimales
de pi, si vous le cherchez
assez loin dans les décimales
et on peut rendre ça encore plus fou si on
passe à une autre
base que la base 10
passons donc en base 27
ou chaque chiffre va être une lettre de l'alphabet
et la 27e lettre va être l'espace
du coup quand on écrit
pi dans cette base 27, on va en fait écrire
des mots, enfin plutôt des lettres
et là vous pouvez vous demander, est-ce que
dans cette suite de lettres,
on peut retrouver n'importe quel mot? Est-ce
que mon prénom par
exemple est quelque part dans cette suite
de lettre ?
Si pi est un nombre normal, vous trouverez
absolument tout dans les décimales
de pi, ou bien les 27 lettres,
en particulier la Bible serait écrite quelque
part dans les
décimales de pi, la déclaration des droits
de l'homme,
tout, tout, tout est dans les décimales de
pi.
Donc finalement ce qui est peut-être le plus
fou avec ce nombre pi,
c'est que ce nombre si anormal on le voit
vraiment partout, on l'a
trouvé en géométrie, en probabilité, en
analyse, ce nombre si anormal si atypique
et bien ce nombre anormal pourrait très bien
être normal
en fait.